we now would like to explore the concept
of potential energy difference for
conservative force let's consider the
following case suppose you have an
object of mass m and it's located at a
certain height Y I initial and so this
is our initial State and we would like
to move this object upwards so it goes
up to a height Y final this is our final
state and in our initial state we might
have some initial velocity and in the
final state we might have some final
speed and what we'd like to do now is we
know that if there's a gravitational
force mg acting downwards that this
gravitational force is a conservative
force and now what I'd like to do is
because the force is conservative it
doesn't depend on the path that our
object goes to the final state it just
depends on the parameters that describe
the initial and the final States
in fact we'll see it only depends on the
initial height and the final height so
what I'd like to do is define a
potential energy difference in the
following way so as a definition the
potential energy difference between
these two points is given by the
negative of the work done by the
gravitational force in going from the
initial state to the final state notice
this negative sign because the
gravitational force here FG is minus mg
j-hat where we're taking j hat up we've
seen that this is an example of a
conservative force and it doesn't matter
how we went from the initial to the
final states so we can generalize this
idea for potential energy but first
let's just remind ourselves of the
calculation when we did this calculation
before we have u final minus u final
initial equals a negative sign in the
definition and when we calculated the
work done by the conservative force we
had
negative mg y final minus y initial
notice the two minus signs so we get mg
y final minus y initial now many times
people talk about changes in potential
energy so when I write Delta U I mean
precisely the potential energy at the
final state minus potential energy the
initial state the change in potential
energy and that's equal to mg times the
change in the displacement and so we see
here for this example that if Delta Y is
positive that implies that the potential
energy is increasing now let's connect
that to our definition Y is the
potential energy increasing when we
raise something well the gravitational
force points downwards the displacement
is upwards so the work done is negative
and another minus sign means the change
of potential energy is positive if the
object is moving with no change in
height that tells us that the potential
energy is change is zero and finally if
Delta Y is less than zero that implies
that the change in potential energy is
negative now again let's examine this
case if we were actually lowering an
object dropping it down the object moved
downward from the initial state to a
final state the gravitational force is
downward the displacement is downward
the integral is positive the extra minus
sign corresponds to the change of
potential energy being negative